[Music]
on this monday night ukraine refuses to
surrender mariupol to russia
moscow's ultimatum rejected while people
run out of places to hide there is no
miracle anymore they bombed everything
the accusations of genocide as roadsides
become cemeteries russian missiles
obliterate a keith mall
and in kirsan protesters targeted with
grenades and guns
aviation disaster the airliner carrying
132 people that plunged from the sky and
a gold mine in the garbage
the canadian technology turning
discarded things into brand new bling
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jackson proskow
good evening and thanks for joining us
ukraine is rejecting russia's demands
that it surrendered the besieged port
city of mariupol where an estimated 300
000 people are trapped as civilians face
the brunt of russian advances conditions
in that city are deteriorating by the
hour as russian forces inflict more
horrors in the capital kiev a shopping
mall was hit by airstrikes killing
several people tonight the u.s says
there's clear evidence russia is
committing war crimes and nato believes
the nearly month-long war is approaching
a stalemate one where neither side can
win mike armstrong begins our coverage
tonight
it is a horror that should be
unimaginable
instead it's easy to find on social
media
these are videos shared to the platform
telegram on a channel called mariupl now
this one shows fire and devastation in
almost every direction
ukraine's defense minister is in london
and not holding back russia is now
committing a real act of genocide
against the ukrainian city of mariupol
the situation on the ground is so
desperate they're burying bodies
anywhere they can as fast as they can
i hope there'll be some sort of
re-burial this man says that this is
just temporary
in normal times mario would have a
population of 400 000 about the size of
london ontario some have escaped but
about three quarters are still trapped
with fewer and fewer places to seek
shelter
everything is destroyed you can see it
for yourself this woman says everything
is broken russian troops have at times
let buses of civilians leave but they're
not letting aid and supplies in a convoy
has been sent according to the red cross
it just hasn't been allowed through
he's stuck
stuck no access so there well
they can go
ukrainian mp says russia is trying to
starve the city into submission
calls it mass murder it's reality there
is no miracle anymore they bombed
everything
now mariupol's location makes it a key
strategic target for russia it sits
between two areas already controlled by
russian forces and would create a land
corridor between them
even back in 2014 russia-backed rebels
tried to take mariupol they held it
briefly but were forced out putin really
wants to show that he can take back with
what he believed belongs to him
ukrainian soldiers were offered safe
passage out of mariupol if they laid
down their weapons and raised white
flags russian forces gave them a
deadline of 4 am local time that offer
was rejected immediately now getting
information out of mariupol is getting
tougher a team from the associated press
that left recently is believed to have
been the last journalists out
these are images taken by that team they
say they were targeted by russian
soldiers literally hunted
and had no choice but to leave
mike armstrong global news jeshof poland
russia's advances on the capital of kiev
took a grim turn as a missile strike
rocked the heart of that city it hit a
shopping mall the blast sparked a huge
fire and sent debris flying through the
area rescuers worked frantically to pull
survivors from the rubble at least eight
people were killed
and in the few places russia has
successfully occupied ukrainians are now
being subjected to new horrors in the
southern city of hirsan they are the
first major urban center to fall russian
troops today opened fire on residents
there who were protesting the invasion
we need to warn you some of these images
are disturbing redmond shannon has our
report
it's another day of devastation in kiev
overnight shelling targeting this large
shopping center
it's hard for me to speak says this
woman my daughter was working here
yesterday just before it happened
vitaly klitschko is advising people to
wear respirator masks and he has ordered
another curfew until wednesday morning
key verse of today is not in full in
circle encirclement there is a route
remaining southeast of kiev
that russians cannot control and
actually according to ukrainian
information the russians were even
pushed back
these babies requiring hospital care
first rushed from eastern ukraine are
now in a cardiac unit 10 kilometers from
key's front line in two months he will
need
open heart surgery
any further russian advance could
threaten critical procedures and lives
on monday russia claimed to have killed
80 ukrainian and foreign soldiers at a
military training center west of kiev
[Music]
in the southern occupied city of carson
protests against russian forces are met
with resistance
ukraine's armed forces says one person
was hurt when civilians were targeted
with gunfire and stun grenades at the
polish border fifteen-year-old botan is
one of almost 3.5 million refugees to
leave so far i think that in a porsche i
feel better because i don't worry about
me
but something i worry about my family
about my mom and dad his mother remains
in kiev caring for his disabled father
an age group helped the boy safely reach
poland the european union is again
warning the world about the threats
faced by so many other children it says
there is a huge risk of child
trafficking on top of the chaos of war
meanwhile germany's foreign minister
says the total number of refugees could
reach 10 million in the coming weeks
jackson
redmond shannon in london thanks redmond
we're learning more about the victims of
the russian attacks on the city of
harkiv including a 96 year old holocaust
survivor relatives say boris romanchenko
died friday when a rocket hit his
apartment building he was deported from
ukraine to germany in 1942 and survived
four nazi concentration camps
romanshenko went on to take an active
role in holocaust commemorations and
explained he was due to be killed just
before he was liberated from the
bergen-belsen camp by allied forces in
april of 1945.
officials in harkeef say russian
assaults on the city have killed at
least 500 residents and more than 600
buildings have been destroyed
in northeastern ukraine russian troops
shelled a chemical plant in sumi causing
toxic ammonia to leak from a 50-ton tank
president zielinski says one person was
injured residents had been told to take
shelter to avoid exposure
ammonia can be deadly if ingested
inhaled or absorbed through the skin the
leak has now been contained
nato believes the war in ukraine may
soon be unwinnable by either side a
stalemate would be long and bloody and
that's adding to the pressure on western
leaders to do something to shift the
balance of power in ukraine's favor nato
leaders including prime minister trudeau
will meet in person later this week and
as heather urex west reports they're
facing calls to take a more direct role
in the conflict
it is the sound the people of ukraine
have been living under for nearly a
month air raid sirens that ukraine's
president is imploring western leaders
help put to an end no euros for the
occupiers vladimir zolensky said close
all your ports to them don't supply them
with goods refuse russian energy
resources push russia to leave ukraine
the most effective role we can continue
to play is by providing that extensive
military assistance that we have been
providing economic and humanitarian
assistance nato leaders will meet in
brussels for a major summit thursday a
meeting of the european council is
planned as well from there the u.s
president will travel to poland
the polish president keen on nato allies
taking a more direct role in the
conflict pressing the u.s to facilitate
the transfer of polish mig fighter jets
while proposing a peacekeeping mission
of armed nato soldiers into ukraine i
think the polish proposal um is a good
one i suspect however that most western
countries don't have the political
backbone
and i suppose for popular support to put
troops in harm's way but short of a
physical intervention there is still
more that nato and its allies can do
including ramping up sanctions to the
point where russia's economy is
completely cut off sometimes
you have to show courage
sometimes
you have to stand up for certain
principles
and take some risks u.s officials have
also issued new warnings that russia may
be planning cyber attacks against
critical infrastructure within the
united states as russia looks for new
avenues to limit the west's ability to
assist ukraine jackson
heather in washington thank you a boeing
jet plunges to the ground in china
coming up the country's worst plane
crash in more than 11 years
plus free in the sea a new home for a
bale of baby sea turtles
we're just here to hold our uh
our dictator accountable
a group of anti-mask mandate protesters
targeted the home of nova scotia's chief
medical officer of health dr robert
strang last night the harassment began
just hours before the province
officially ended its two-year-long covit
19 state of emergency and lifted most
public health measures
you know that it's concerning well i was
up until well after two o'clock with
prank phone calls and things like that
so very
juvenile and
kind of unwelcome behavior that i know
the majority of vast majority of nova
scotians do not support that at all
strang thanked the rcmp for assistance
in dealing with the situation during a
facebook live stream of the protest one
demonstrator could be heard telling an
officer they wanted to speak to strang
about last week's decision to extend
masking in public schools
and as of today in nova scotia there are
no province-wide restrictions on
gatherings and no social distancing or
mask mandates other than in high-risk
settings like hospitals and long-term
care homes the mass mandate for schools
will remain in place until at least
mid-april that decision follows advice
from a group of pediatric doctors who
warned that while case counts and
hospitalizations are declining they
still remain high
as kovit 19 restrictions ease right
across canada ontario is the latest
province to remove mass mandates
scrapping them in most public spaces as
abigail beeman reports not everyone is
ready to take that step
walking out masks on these students
protest the end of a mask mandate in
ontario schools our group has pushed for
access for a 95 mass pursuit that's not
happening an equity issue so as others
maps come off i feel the need to upgrade
coven might spread again and we don't
want to see the numbers rising once
scientists are approved for this
decision i will be safe in children who
are average risk um we really don't have
the data to tell us that this is an
important you know measure this family
doctor and former child and family
therapist says there isn't enough
science neither on how well masks
actually work to stop the spread in the
classroom nor on long-term development
and social impacts kids need to watch
sound um and vowel pronunciation coming
from their teachers mouths and when they
can't see that it affects their ability
to to learn how to read
right and these are skills that are
meant to happen at certain developmental
stages ontario is the sixth province to
drop school mass mandates this month bc
will follow after spring break pei and
the yukon still require masks in school
so do nova scotia nunavut the northwest
territories and newfoundland and
labrador but that may change in the next
few weeks meanwhile in the u.s hawaii
remains the only state with a classroom
mask mandate the risk of severe illness
for children with kovid remains very low
hospitalizations do remain a fairly rare
outcome and probably on par to what we
might see during a bad influenza season
and and yet we don't mandate mask
wearing for influenza but after wearing
a mask in the classroom for so long
opinions are mixed about taking them off
and not everyone will i'm so happy
because myself i didn't like wearing
masks you feel comfortable i'd like you
to still stay in your mask and they were
quite happy about it i think the masks
are actually developmentally
not great so i think it's time
change can be tough for kids and experts
say for some this was bound to be a
difficult day no matter the decision
abigail beeman global news ottawa
in hong kong some of the world's
toughest pandemic measures are set to
ease next month hong kong's chief
executive carrie lamb says her
government will lift a ban on flights
from nine countries including canada as
of april first schools and businesses
will begin reopening later in the month
but no timetable was given for
resumption of travel between hong kong
and mainland china where cases have
surged to their highest numbers of the
pandemic
china is in mourning over its worst air
disaster in over a decade a boeing 737
jet operated by china eastern airlines
was carrying 132 people when it went
down in a remote mountainous area in
southern china there are reports the
aircraft suddenly entered a steep dive
and crashed about 90 seconds later
nearby villagers were first to discover
the extensive trail of debris no
survivors have been found family members
have now gathered at the airport in
guangzhou where the plane was headed and
arrangements are being made for travel
to the crash site
chinese state media says the airline's
entire fleet of 737 800 has been
grounded
ground to a halt will a cp rail work
stoppage derail the supply chain
[Music]
a cp rail work stoppage is into its
second day with conductors engineers and
train and yard workers off the job the
federal government is facing pressure to
end the stoppage labor minister seamus
o'regan is in calgary where negotiations
are underway o'regan says talks have
been productive but there's no timeline
for when 3 000 workers will be back at
work
david aiken has the details
back in the house of commons after a
two-week recess the opposition demanded
the government do something to end the
cp rail work stoppage so what is the
government's plan to immediately resolve
this dispute several industry groups
representing cp rail's biggest customers
well they have the answer this is very
time sensitive hours matter and we're
urging mps and senators to address this
through back to work legislation but the
trudeau government for now is trusting
both sides to reach a deal they are
working hard no one has left the table
our party believes that the best deals
are reached at the table in any event
back to work legislation could run into
an ndp hurdle in the house of commons
in 2011 the ndp led by jack leighton led
a three-day-long filibuster against back
to work legislation during a canada post
strike you can count on us to pose back
to work legislation again meanwhile
experts warn a lengthy rail service
disruption would almost certainly cause
food prices to spike and might even
cause food shortages later in the year
that's because those idled rail cars are
normally carrying fertilizer for crops
which will soon be planted all eyes are
on north america to deliver to help out
from a global food security perspective
and you have to think about fertilizers
agricultural output later this year
so there's lots going on here other rail
cars would be filled with feed for
hungry western canada cattle this could
be the most devastating thing that we've
seen and it's human caused
and from our point of view it's very
easy for humans to fix this problem and
we as everybody here said we don't have
a lot of time and even if this cp work
stoppage ended after four or five days
consider this in 2018 cn rail had a work
stoppage it lasted eight days
but it took six weeks to get supply
chains back to normal jackson david
aiken in ottawa thanks
prince william and kate are on a tour of
central america and the caribbean to
strengthen britain's ties with
commonwealth countries the week-long
visit will take the royal couple to
belize jamaica and the bahamas and comes
just months after barbados cut ties with
the queen it was organized at the
queen's request as she marked 70 years
on the throne but local opposition
forced prince william and kate to scrap
a planned visit to a cacao farm in
belize on saturday and their upcoming
trip to jamaica has angered a group of
people calling for slavery reparations
and an apology for colonialism
well from bits to bucks next mining the
fortune inside your old electronics
well there are big things ahead for
these little fellas conservation
officials in india released 150 baby sea
turtles into the indian ocean the
species which is believed to have been
around for more than 100 million years
is under threat due to human activities
including poaching habitat destruction
and the effects of climate change
and our impact on the planet isn't
limited to animals as we keep ditching
our old gadgets for new ones toxic
electronic waste is becoming a major
problem and that has prompted the uk's
royal mint to quite literally turn trash
into cash and they're doing it with the
technique developed right here in canada
ross lord reports
in a consumer society that's
increasingly hooked on electronics an
old adage has new meaning one person's
trash is another's treasure inside those
printed circuit boards and on those
printed circuit boards um are precious
metals in a laden with precious metals
and unfortunately seven percent of the
gold in the world is in these
electronics this discarded electronics
right now only 18 of the planet's
e-waste is recycled the rest 54 million
tons per year is essentially burned
releasing toxic byproducts
but the royal mint in the uk says it's
opening a new plant to extract gold and
other precious metals to use in its
coins the mint's partner is a canadian
startup exer of calgary axia is not
speaking to media but the mint is
singing its praises for a patented
chemical process this chemistry is able
to
remove 99 of the gold that's sitting on
these circuit boards to a 99.99
purity
of course all that glitters is not
new canadian recyclers say they've been
doing similar work since 2007. they use
metal from our electronics to make uh
the metals for the 2010 so
yes we've been doing it for a long time
vancouver olympic medals included small
bits of recycled electronics while the
royal canadian mint recycles by keeping
coins in circulation the uk royal man
says its plant will clean out up to 90
tons of uk circuit boards per week
extracting hundreds of kilograms almost
immediately including gold silver and
copper they'll be melted down into new
coins welcome renewal from a venerable
institution
ross lord global news
and that's global national for this
monday night i'm jackson proskow a
number of canadians are likely thinking
about their own ties to ukraine these
days and we'll leave you with a big one
this is the world's largest pisangka
located in vegeville alberta pasankas
are a ukrainian tradition they're
hand-decorated easter eggs given as a
charm to bring good fortune and fend off
evil spirits
thanks for watching and i hope you'll
join us again tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you